أعتقد أن معظمهم سيوافقون على أنها قطع
دجاج لذيذة المظهر ،
لكن قد تفاجأ عندما تعلم
أن اللحم الموجود بداخلها لم يُزرع على
لحم وعظم دجاج
ولكن في المختبر يكون لحم دجاج على الرغم من أنه
ليس بديلاً
، يتم نسخ جميع الخلايا من
تم تحقيق هذا الدجاج المسمى إيان من قبل شركة
ناشئة في كاليفورنيا تسمى Eat
فقط واحدة من عدة شركات في سباق عالي
المخاطر
للحصول على لحوم مخبرية لتسويق
لحوم الدجاج المستزرع في
جهاز يسمى مفاعل حيوي من
خلال عملية يقول مبتكروها
يشبه بيولوجيًا
تخمير البيرة في ديسمبر ،
أصبحت سنغافورة أول
دولة توافق على بيع الدجاج المزروع في المختبر في
نهاية المطاف ، فإن خطة الشركة هي
تقديم مجموعة واسعة من اللحوم المزروعة
بما في ذلك المأكولات البحرية ولحم البقر
إذا كنت تعتقد أن كل هذا يبدو
وكأنه  حيلة معرض العلوم غير المجدية
التفكير مرة أخرى تتمتع اللحوم المستزرعة
بإمكانيات ثورية
وفقًا لمنظمة الأغذية والزراعة التابعة للأمم المتحدة ،
يذبح الجنس البشري حاليًا  الحصول على
80 مليار حيوان سنويًا من أجل الغذاء
حيث يمكن للدجاج أن يشهد
على أكثر الفوائد المحتملة وضوحًا
لهذه التكنولوجيا أنها يمكن أن تلغي الحاجة إلى
قتل أي حيوانات من أجل لحومها ،
وهناك تداعيات كبيرة في هذه الفكرة
على رفاهية الحيوان
لا مزيد من الظروف اللاإنسانية في المصنع
المزارع ولصحة الإنسان
بعد أن انتقلت جميع الأمراض الفتاكة مثل إنفلونزا الخنازير
إلى البشر من حيوانات المزرعة
التي تتأثر أيضًا بفيروس
كورونا
وربما الأهم من ذلك أن اللحوم المزروعة في المختبر
يمكن أن تكون نقطة تحول في
معركة البشرية ضد
تغير المناخ وذلك بسبب تربية
الماشية من أجل  الاستهلاك البشري
هو السبب الرئيسي لانبعاثات الكربون
وفقًا لدراسة جديدة نُشرت
في لانسيت ،
فإن النظام الغذائي مسؤول عن 20 إلى
30 في المائة
من انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري العالمية
التي ينشأ معظمها من اللحوم ومنتجات الألبان
في كتابه الذي يبلغ مليار دولار من
مراسل برجر مطاردة  يلاحظ بيردي
أن بقرة واحدة تنتج حوالي مائة
كيلوغرام من الأمتار  الإيثان
هو نفسه تقريبًا مثل سيارة تحترق من خلال
230 جالونًا من البنزين
لوضع ذلك في الاعتبار ، فهذا يعني
أن بقرتين فقط تنتجان
نفس الكمية تقريبًا من غازات الاحتباس
الحراري سنويًا كما تفعل السيارة الجديدة
المباعة في أمريكا في عام على
الطريق
بمجرد أن تعرف  يبلغ عدد
رؤوس الماشية
في جميع أنحاء العالم 1.5 مليار ، يجب أن
يتضح كيف أصبحت تربية حيوانات المزرعة ملوثة لأن
زراعة اللحوم المستزرعة لها
بصمة أصغر بكثير تخلق
جزءًا صغيرًا من
الانبعاثات وهي أكثر كفاءة بكثير وجدت دراسة أجريت عام 2011
أنه في حين  لا يزال
إنتاج اللحوم المستزرعة كثيفًا للطاقة ، ويتضمن
استخدامًا أقل للأراضي بنسبة تصل إلى 99 في المائة ،
وانبعاثات غازات دفيئة أقل بنسبة
تصل إلى 96 في المائة ، واستخدام أقل للمياه بنسبة تصل إلى 96 في المائة
مقارنة باللحوم المنتجة تقليديًا
عندما تنظر إليها بهذه الطريقة ،
وقد يكون الأمر صغيرًا.  الثمن
الذي يجب دفعه والإجابة على السؤال الذي
قد تفكر
فيه بنعم ، يبدو أنه حقًا طعمه مثل
الدجاج